By this time, we know how to
construct confidence intervals
when we try to estimate an
unknown mean of a certain
distribution using the sample
mean as our estimator.
Or actually, these are
approximate confidence
intervals, because we are
using the approximation
suggested by the central
limit theorem.
But what if we do not know the
value of sigma, the standard
deviation of the X's?
Then we have a few options.
One option is to use an
upper bound on sigma.
So we will be using a
value that's larger
than or equal to sigma.
And this is going to make our
interval somewhat larger.
So this is a conservative
choice, but it is
definitely an option.
For example, if we're dealing
with Bernoulli random
variables, we know that the
standard deviation is less
than or equal to 1/2, so we can
just plug-in the value of
1/2 at this point.
Another option is to try
to estimate sigma.
How do we estimate it?
We can perhaps use an ad hoc
estimate of sigma that fits to
the particular situation
at hand.
So for example, in the Bernoulli
case, we know that
sigma is given by this formula,
where theta is the
mean of the Bernoulli.
And using this, and since we do
have an estimate of theta--
this is just the sample mean--
we can plug-in that particular
estimate.
And that gives us an estimate
of the standard deviation.
When n is large, this estimate
is going to be very close to
the true value.
And so this estimate of the
standard deviation will also
be very close to
the true value.
Both of these options were
discussed for special cases
where we have special structure
and we can derive an
upper bound, or there is
a natural estimate
that suggests itself.
More generally, what
can we do?
One general option is to
use a generic way of
estimating the variance.
And here's how it goes.
The variance is, by definition,
the expected value
of something, of this
expression.
And we can estimate expected
values by taking several
samples of this quantity, and
taking the average of them.
So if we have n pieces of data,
for each piece of data,
we calculate this quantity,
divide by n.
And by the weak law of large
numbers, this is the sample
mean of this particular
random variable.
And it converges to
the expected value
of this random variable.
So that's how we could estimate
the variance.
But there is a catch.
This expression here
involves the mean
of the random variable.
And this is something
that we do not know.
So what can we do?
Well, we have an estimate for
the mean, so we could just
plug in that estimate instead
of the true value.
And this gives us this
alternative expression.
Now, when n is very large, as n
increases, this sample mean
converges to the true mean.
So this expression here would
become closer and closer to
this expression.
Now, this expression converges
to sigma squared, and we
conclude from this that this
expression will also converge
to sigma squared.
And so here we have a way of
estimating sigma squared from
the data, and by taking the
square root, we obtain an
estimate of sigma as well that
we can plug in in this
expression.
And this gives us a complete
way of coming up with
confidence intervals when we
only have data available in
our hands, but do not know ahead
of time what sigma is.
Some remarks.
This procedure of constructing
confidence intervals involves
two separate approximations.
One approximation has to do with
the fact that the sample
mean is approximately normal
according to the
central limit theorem.
And then there is a second
approximation that comes in in
using an estimate of sigma
instead of the
true value of sigma.
Now, when we estimate sigma
instead of using the true
value, we're introducing
some additional
randomness in this procedure.
And because of this randomness,
the confidence
intervals actually should
be a little larger.
There is a systematic way of
doing that, and it involves
using the so-called
t-distribution tables.
And those tables are going to
give us certain numbers that
are a little different from
what we have here.
So instead of 1.96, we might
have a somewhat larger number.
This correction is relevant
when n is a small number,
let's say n smaller than 30.
But for larger values of n, this
correction, where we use
t tables instead of normal
tables, is rather
insignificant and one doesn't
bother with it.
In any case, we will not discuss
any further this
additional correction, but it
is useful to know that it is
something that the statisticians
will often do.
Finally, one last remark.
One will often see an
alternative way of estimating
the variance where instead of
this factor of 1/n, one uses a
factor of 1 over n minus 1.
With this alternative form, it
turns out that this is an
unbiased estimator
of the variance.
And that could be a reason for
preferring to use this
alternative form.
On the other hand, when n is
large, whether we use n or n
minus 1 makes very little
difference.
And this concludes
our discussion
of confidence intervals.